i [ __ ] with yellowstone you guys watch
that [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ]
yellowstone is the [ __ ] yeah you [ __ ]
block mine all the goddamn time he
blocked brian all the guys
yeah [ __ ] it
man
yellowstone i go to vacation with my
family in montana because of yellowstone
dude yellow specification over
yellowstone almost yeah
are you on 1883 though what's what do
you mean 1883's that's the yellowstone
it's on paramount plus no bro it might
be better than yellowstone whoa that's
[ __ ] good and taylor did that one as
well right rider same director taylor
sheridan
yeah he's the one on the horses
yeah i get a little annoyed with him in
yellowstone because he's always like
showing off i rode horses all the
[ __ ] time you know he's doing the
horse shimmy and [ __ ]
get out of the [ __ ] chair yeah they
they go a little heavy with the horse
tricks yeah it's like 10 minutes
bouncing
what the horse could do yeah
yeah they're stopping it's like but the
[ __ ] violence in it and the
1883 might be better oh [ __ ] good you
saw every how the i one of the greatest
episodes of any show i've ever seen ever
was yellowstone episode one season four
that was i couldn't even believe what i
was watching violence like after because
because it ends season three ends
because
yes
season three ends where all the main
characters have an ordeal
and oh you think everybody's dead and
then and then episode one of season four
i'm like i can't even believe it's a
pretty violent show oh it's over dude
it'll go violent and then chill for a
while violent of [ __ ] machine gun
episode one of season four the episode
one season four and like rip and all
them come back you know it's like
[ __ ] dude this it's like [ __ ] it's
like cowboy mafia [ __ ]
like they're essentially a mafia it's
like somebody said it's like the
sopranos in like present day montana
with cowboys okay fighting overlapping
he's trying to protect his land and then
all these new builders are trying to
take over the land yeah
it's been family land dude i'll binge
till four o'clock guys
you have to calm down you it's you
you're so excited that you keep
interrupting and you're like
with his hands right now dude i wanted
to buy a big [ __ ] belt buckle when i
saw that [ __ ] like those big
i bought a cowboy hat champion yeah i
no the show will do that my buddy uh
kevin ryan he does are you garbage yeah
he goes dude i'm in i'm like two
episodes in he goes i'm thinking about
getting like go to zillow to get [ __ ]
a ranch like when you watch that [ __ ]
you're gonna start yeah
there was uh what's his name's great in
it too uh cole hauser oh rip you're
talking right rip dude you watch it or
not no i just know about how how good of
an actor is beth you know she's english
i couldn't believe that when i saw the
one with the red hair
she's reddish blonde hair she's like
[ __ ] oh who is she she's just so
british
dude in that in that show dude she's
naked 24 7. she's got she's so gangster
oh and i heard she's such a woman man
she's from the united states she has got
a damn body those are natural and by the
way she's older she's
she's so good in this and she's
says sexy
kevin costner is great in it costner's
still kind of gangster man yeah he is
yeah he is costner's still got a little
bit of that's well that's the guy tr uh
travis
yeah that's rip that's right that's
called houser yeah his character is just
his character is just whatever whatever
the boss needs
he just he's he's like the he's like
heavy he's like he's like yeah that's a
great way he's like luca i mean but i'm
more confident but yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's my favorite show that was
that was sammy the bull they would say
like gotti or something yeah it's like
he doesn't ask questions dirty
would be like can you take care of this
he'd be like
yeah i got it yeah kevin costello same
thing he's like hey take care of it then
he gets it done that's that's his his
character like he could just do
something yes
without a question because he brought
him in he brought him in as a kid so
he's like the big muscle like the
[ __ ] he's just like whatever needs he
goes to him and then he's he's in charge
of the ranch like the boys on the ranch
yeah cowboys and when they fight he goes
hey if you're going to fight somebody
you have to fight me you don't fight
each other you fight me you want to
fight somebody fight me
[ __ ] everybody up yeah that's so funny
because like that's the character i hear
about the most even though i haven't
seen the show but his character is the
character if he's mad at you in the show
and he just starts even his walk you're
like oh this dude's [ __ ] like he just
he'll walk up and just grab me and just
start beating the [ __ ] out of somebody
yeah it's crazy damn it's a good show
man my fave
i